everybody right now
[Music]
NFL retirees Tom Brady and Rob
Gronkowski compete again but this time
they're shirtless on the beach and it's
giving total top gun Vibes when you stop
playing football you know it's usually a
tough transition and I just want to find
things that you love to do that you like
to do and and go out and do it and do it
at full speed and the guys felt the need
or speed reuniting with some of their
former New England Patriot teammates for
a beach day with friends and family
[Music]
.
you look familiar to you it sure does
the video looks a lot like the top gun
Maverick scene featuring Tom Cruise and
Miles Teller also shirtless
[Music]
Rock's girlfriend Camille kostick who
shared the video jokes in the caption
adding cinematographer to my resume Top
Gun 3 sneak peek I think we would have
so much fun with that now Tom being in a
movie isn't too out of the box seems he
was bit by the acting bug after making
his big screen debut in 80 for Brady the
Super Bowl is no place for four old
women this could be Tom's last one he's
almost 40. let's go oh my God
because let's see I don't know make some
offers let's see what we could do all
right football movies the booth what's
next well trying to figure it out so
just taking it day by day and my friend
says the future happens a day at a time
so that's what life's all about in the
meantime it looks like Tom's putting all
his focus on his kids following his
divorce from Gisele Bundchen I'm so
driven to succeed in football and that's
taken me away from
other important priorities which are my
kids my wife the former athletes kids
were also at the beach bash son Benjamin
and daughter Vivian whom he shares with
Giselle and his son jack who he shares
with ex Bridget Moynihan you get to see
him develop and you see these different
parts of their life and they teach you
so much I mean the kids are so wonderful
yeah the retired life clearly looks good
on Tom
swimming in the place
[Music]